cam newton uh mike reese had an
interesting nugget over the weekend you
got a great column every sunday that
looks at various
little issues and news items relating to
the patriots he wrote that cam newton
spent time working with a throwing coach
rebuilding some of his fundamentals in
the offseason and now that he was back
last week for phase two and they were
out on the field actually doing things
teammates were impressed by the progress
that cam newton has made remember two
years ago he completely revamped his
throwing motion after shoulder surgery
we forgot about that because he was done
for the year with a foot injury week too
but cam newton making some tweaks
working
toward doing whatever he needs to do to
be better with the patriots and the
message is so far so good based upon
what people saw last week yeah that's
what you hear that it looked good i mean
let's not forget yeah he needs work we
know that it was it was choppy as hell
you know the second half of 2020. it was
all over the place
you know but at the same time let's not
forget that early in the year you know
before colvin and some of those things
he was in rhythm and throwing dimes and
lasers all over the football field you
know so you know you you talk about like
yeah i've seen some of this stuff i know
he did a few weeks ago he had a video
like george whitfield on instagram with
him throwing and things like that yeah
he has to
last year mechanics fell apart after he
came back from coven and i think when
you talk about like mike yeah you know
this is a guy that's still he's got a
gifted arm there's no doubt about it but
he's had a lot of hiccups that have
taken him out of the rhythm of throwing
the last two years you know yeah like
you said played played one year was
playing awesome
hurt his shoulder
tried to play through that year with the
pain that could cause bad mechanics the
next year you come back you've rested
the shoulder done all those things tried
to change it a little hurt the foot
you're never really getting a new rhythm
of like the new mechanics or the things
you got to do then last year yeah he got
it going but i i do want to make sure
people understand like
it's not easy
you know and especially for a guy who
yes has to stay on top of his mechanics
to stay in rhythm for a guy to go
through a quarterback especially in a
new spot a new offense all those type of
things mike and i know you've heard me
say this before but you're in rhythm
you're trying to learn you're thinking
about mechanics hey go sit in the hotel
room for three weeks you can't throw
can't do anything can't work out can't
you can't do crap
oh now you're coming back you're playing
in the game we need you to throw strikes
hit the outside corner hit the inside
corner do that do that no it didn't work
and it fell apart from there i still got
faith in the guy i can't lie and i
expect them to be better
can we pop that graphic back up please
because my math skills have deteriorated
yes and years but that looks like sixty
percent of all of his throws were either
behind the line of scrimmage or within
zero to nine yards from the line of
scrimmage six out of ten throws
either
screens little dump offs behind the line
of scrimmage or short passes beyond that
that is amazing yeah chris he's got to
get the ball down the field more now
this may be a product of not having the
weapons that that that's the thing that
you there's always patriots fans who
have decided that cam newton sucks right
and they get upset when you say he could
still be pretty good and then when they
drafted mac jones see he sucks wait a
minute wait a minute he didn't have the
help last year and bill belichick's
gonna gonna go with the guy that helps
the team win he doesn't care right he
doesn't care if they spent the 15th
overall pick on mac jones whoever's
going to help the team win is the guy
that's going to play is it newton then
it's him is it mack jones then it's him
it's pure and total meritocracy when it
comes to who gets on the field and this
year there's better guys on the field
around him so maybe he can get the ball
down the field a little bit more yeah
definitely i mean there's just so many
things that went into last year and went
into the demise of his throwing and
everything like that yeah you know took
a few weeks off from mentally growing
within the offense julian edelman gets
hurt in that period now he's not as good
you know the receivers were crappy to
begin with you know so all of it you
know they played a few good football
teams it just all kind of hit that spot
where yeah it fell apart and throwing
he's definitely got to fix it there's no
doubt about that i do believe he can
we've seen him do that and hey the
biggest thing we know
out of anything is
i mean
new england brought new england must
think this
new england didn't didn't just like well
he was so crappy and horrible let's
bring them back man there was nothing to
like but let's bring them back you know
let's piss the fan base off no
they obviously know that you know the
the odds were stacked against him last
year there was a lot of issues they know
their football team wasn't perfect he
still is a great leader he has a
presence on the field he puts way more
pressure on defenses than people give
him credit for i know his past game
stats aren't that good when you add it
with his rush stats and some of the
things he does that way the stats don't
look that bad you got to remember that
too that's part of his game is running
the ball and doing that stuff so you
know i'm rooting for them because i'm
kind of sick of everybody hating on them
i can say that much
julian adam last week on the michael
urban podcast we played this and reacted
to it on friday when chris was sound
asleep i want chris to hear what edelman
had to say about cam newton and we'll
talk about that a little bit more on the
other side here's edelman from last week
with michael irvin
last year was an absolute like joke
which it was i mean
you know these these the covid stuff i
mean you can you couldn't have a routine
there was like so many
regulations and spacing and trackers i
don't think it was fair to see um
you know with with how cam had to go
through that you know what i mean and
i'm gonna be very interested to see how
he goes this year because he's got now
he's got a year under his belt
my guy's probably working his tail off
on all his reeds you know he's he's
probably been working hard that's that's
his mo kim works hard you know now we
gotta we gotta see if he can work smart
in the right areas and if he does that
he's gonna give himself an opportunity
to do well you know what i mean you know
but
he's also gonna have to beat out the
young gun
because the young gun is there a little
mac attack whatever you know this this
kid you know you know
that's a that's a
a first-round draft pick that's like a
real first-round draft pick
yeah it is that's a guy that was going
to go number three overall to the 49ers
until he didn't in mac jones so that is
a real first round draft pick hovering
over cam newton's shoulder and work hard
versus work smart
hey i understand that concept try to do
both if you can but you don't want to
spin your wheels in the mud you want to
find a way to put in effort that is
going to make you better and maybe last
year cam didn't fully understand how to
work smart within the confines of the
patriots offense it was a new experience
for him he's got a year under his belt
he can focus his efforts on where he
needs to and it sounds like he's already
done that in the offseason at the behest
presumably
of josh mcdaniels and or bill belichick
who told him here's what you need to
work on on your own time here's where
you need to be better when we get
together again in may yeah i think i
think that's why they you know signed
them up you know and got that ball
rolling pretty early in the process once
they realized they might not get a trade
they wanted or anything like that so
they can get rolling on those type of
things that we're talking about hey he's
a smart guy there's no doubt we've
always heard he worked hard i think like
julian edelman put it perfectly you know
smart and right areas you know it's just
like the guy like hey hey the guy at the
gym he's doing you know he's doing bench
press his pecs are gigantic great you
know but your arms and your chest are
bigger than your legs man we need to get
in the squat machine or you're not have
any real power so now he's got to work
smart like cam newton i think what
julian edelman is now saying is like
listen we know you work hard you're a
leader now you got to get into like
nuances of the offense and really master
that i think that's what he's talking
about when he's talking about working
smart you know the things you weren't
good at you know ball placement accuracy
those type of things it's got to improve
this year and especially to to what he
said like the guy he's got coming in
there mac jones is really special in
those areas so it's going to be it's
going to show itself even more
when you talk about accuracy and the
great decisions and processing
information those are mac jones staples
that's why everybody loved them and
that's where you know cam's going to
have to make those improvements but last
year was tough as julian edelman said
i'm glad he stated that at least
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports